I think tattoos are the ultimate
expression of self because you get to
put something on your body that you get
to go to the grave with and it's cool to
know that when he's dead
somebody doesn't know him they could
look at his arm but hey he likes the
Undertaker from wrestling I met Eric
when I was like four or five years old
on my block 31st Street and I met you
and fourth grade ps1 ps1 19
my first tattoo I was 15 Shh it's like
this clown right here
that's very evil and scary with guns and
[ __ ] and I want something that's like
scary where are you going so I was
Avenue just the first acts love that
says I can't see them coming down my
eyes you know it's nice little jay-z
with your ass shut up jay-z as a man
with no tattoos that's pretty cool yeah
I draw a lot so it's so much more than I
feel like I would want to do to it it
would just my whole body would be you
probably a tattoo I have I addictive
personality like that got it like you
know prioritize I could be like for me
I'm in my right hand and front part of
my body for my use and I'm making my
left hand my left leg and my back and
when I'm old
some people think some people don't was
that a plan yeah when I got my first
dumb tattoo I realize all right it was
just like I got meat against the world
in the my arms at the time this ha spell
I don't get mad at it when I look at it
because I was 19 that's how I learned
though I would never feel stupid for any
tattoo out of that I have when I spelt
wrong that I don't doesn't bother me
what's this one the thing is this one
right here life that represents the game
of life the higher consciousness the
universe the plants the trees the heart
the Sun and Moon I said that means I got
that one on 16
we both have Biggie Smalls on our body I
just got that cuz I love the G smalls
and like you know that's one of the most
important people to like my life and
he's the way Jesus be so I figure I wear
it as my Jesus spare me your grievances
hip-hop saved my life so I put biggie
right who Jesus is
well I was gonna point here you know
it's right on my heart I would show
mine's on my heart but it to Harry
dearly miss my tattoos that are buried
beneath my hair I have B small C or my
mom's name here and I have Sam be here
what are your hand I know what that is
though this is nirvana kids yeah it's a
band
those who do what he was like listen man
my tattoos will go through to the grave
man I'm telling you they don't rubble
off they own it every tattoo he's done
everyone that night rubbed off swelled
swole this [ __ ] was swollen he didn't
cut through my kermis epidermis you
attacked with my bone he was drunk as
hell and I just wanted my Nirvana tattoo
so bad it didn't matter to me yeah my he
doing for me I was like performing and a
kid in the crowd scratched my hand so
now I'd like a little stupid mark there
I definitely don't trust the person
that's gonna give it to me and I think
that's why I have a tattoo as well and
I'm drawing I'm very very very like
particular and if the person that's not
me is doing that on my body I just feel
weird about that [ __ ] sometimes about
just connecting with that person I
haven't linkie from the citizens over
here that's not a hard tattoo to do but
the person knew the Simpsons what they
knew the character so that energy is
still going to my show I like the female
tattoo artists more I thought they'll
really take care of detail way more
attention to detail this skeleton right
here was
homegirl cake she'll sleep a zombie and
my homegirl irizar Bush did my gon and
killua
tattoos she also did my dog right here
you know we always wanted to be you know
they're gonna be even be a wrestling
group world's WrestleMania one day but
smoke stunts I broke or something I
don't know Vincent Kennedy McMahon you
are the Flatbush zombies and we are
internationally known to kick ass all
across the squared circle
till next time at WrestleMania when you
need someone I got if you Scratchy
obviously there's my blinky from The
Simpsons this is my friend yams made him
both my face tattoos at the same time in
Toronto
Harry was answer sign now the UNK you
know instead of putting like money on
the [ __ ] but something that's very
important to not only meet with the
world I like them someone doesn't know
the on peers and they say hey what's
that cross on your face and I say do
your Google's kid
listen this is bold as love right yeah
that's a Jimmy Andres track all of our
friends like one of our favorite songs
to listen to when we're in psychedelic
so just in general I had an afro when I
had just a two he has like X's in his
eyes
these aren't like for cause this is for
life when you're trippin balls that was
deep
so you want to take your shirt off and
show me the very one this is the LSD
chemical makeup so if you're a scientist
or wherever in a cave one day I always
said I'm always not on the acid so we'll
need anybody
I thought the guards first tattoo will
be Morris the cat is a cat used a vile
didn't get that cat tattoo the other day
Donna and if I could pick their tattoo
for Harry it would be a portrait of his
mom and then a portrait of his dead as
well run into I'll pick one of those I
love that cat I love my parents
I feel like those are things I would
never get tired of seeing ever do I have
a tattoo for that so I don't have I have
this tattoo here that says hell hath no
fury this is so I never get a woman
statue
so I [ __ ] up I like that when I was 18
when I first walked up I'm reminded
every day of that every day when I wake
up not to teach not to [ __ ] up but if
you talk to the girl's name only you
might have [ __ ] up if you talk to the
guys in England you might a knife like
that or it might have been the biggest
best thing you ever did who knows or you
were just drunk
[Music]